on June 24 1947 a pilot named Kenneth
Arnold saw nine disc shaped objects near
Mount Rainier Washington which was the
first reported UFO sighting and one
factor in the decision to create Project
Blue Book a team of investigators with
the U.S Air Force that over 17 years
studied the veracity of these claims by
the time it dissolved in 1969 the group
had studied nearly 13
000 UFO sightings concluding that almost
all of them could be attributed to other
phenomena five percent however are still
unexplained now UAP focused startups are
popping up everywhere seemingly their
goal is to contend for military
contracts do you think the government
knows more about UFOs or uaps than
they're letting on the government's this
big oh very difficult to get with to
grips with very complicated organization
with lots of moving parts that don't
talk to each other the government knows
more about everything that is willing to
tell us it's dubious that it knows
anything about UFOs being aliens though